why I like to save the goats that's a
question I have often been asking myself
because I can't answer it this is
somehow my mission to take care of the
goats somebody had to do it and I fall
in love with them my name is Johanna
Burt Massaro stilted and I'm a goat
farmer in Iceland for the last 16 years
I have been trying to build up and
protect or goat breed they have been
isolated in Iceland for 1,100 years they
came by the Vikings from Norway and from
Scotland Ireland though I haven't go to
twice been less than 100 animals in 1962
there was just about 6070 goats left
they have been a very big tension of
both inbreeding and disappearing I got
them here and since then they'd have
been my passion to breed up this type of
the gods this is the only farm we are
trying to live from the goats
to milk them and make products if you
are trying to save a breed you have to
use what they give we have been doing a
lot of different things to raise
attention for the goats that Game of
Thrones for shooting here 20 of the
goats were used
they would not be here anymore if I
wouldn't have taken care of them I'm
very proud to look at my floss and see
that they are life because of my work
it's just like when you have children
you are proud of them I'm very proud of
my goats